now let's just quickly check does this
make sense of what you observe okay get
your calculator out for a second I'm go
to calculate a bit I want you to try out
a number like say well what radius would
you like to try a simple number how
about over even smaller than that like
all right at the beginning of things
right what about when you first started
putting air into the balloon
okay what about when I'm not going to
put in R equals zero because then I'm
dividing my zero it that's a bit of a
downer okay let's try something nice and
small like R equals one if you put R
equals one into here what number do you
get out five point five point five seven
okay I might write that down that might
be handy for me when R is equal to one
dr on DT is five point five seven okay
so that's what happens when you start
now is that is that fast or slow well I
don't have much of a handle on it let me
see if I can compare to some numbers
let's see what happens once the radius
doubles right well you've got the same
equation down here the same formula you
can pop your value into you what value
do you get four are i sorry dr/dt about
your pan one point okay now just pause
before we put in another number what's
happening well the balloon is getting
bigger alright the blue is getting
bigger it's gone from one centimeter
radius to two centimeters radius but
what's happening to dr/dt it's slowing
down it's decreasing it's slowing down
really fast right but do know it's still
positive right it hasn't gone negative
or anything like that why is it positive
you're still blowing air in okay so it's
growing but it's not it's not going as
fast let's go one more just for good
measure put in three okay what's going
to happen once the radius is three
centimeters
zero point
so I think that's enough just to see
what's going on okay the radius is
slowly now and that is exactly what you
can observe as you go from here right
even though my lungs are pretty pathetic
you can see from three breaths to four
breaths to five breaths it barely moves
at all the radius right do you notice
that okay but this huge changes here
between one and two
does that make sense you with me okay
good let's think about surface area now
I haven't put anything on the board here
that relates to that I am I rubbed it
off before but I want I'm interested in
da on DT well how am I going to get to
DA on DT think about how we did it over
here I'm gonna need to combine some
derivatives and you're gonna have to
help me work out where we're going to
get these reviews what movies do you
think would be suitable to combine to
give you da or DT figure out how we did
it before any suggestions d/dr over DT
so I can combine this human DRN DT and
which other one you want to compare it
with you got the DT on the bottom what's
going to be at the top what do you want
to be on the top you want the DA up
there and the D are down the bond you
see that's gonna cancel second away so
how am I going to get either of these I
know what dr/dt is I worked that out how
can I work at da on D are da on D are
you can use that you actually know a
surface area formula for a sphere right
now I just watch out here there's
something strange and interesting that
I'm not gonna explain yet I just want
you to notice the area formula for the
surface area of a sphere happens to be 4
PI R squared now I've written four PI R
squared on the board already about three
minutes ago but these two things are
really different right like that's a
derivative that's a rate of change this
is just well it's a it's a size it's
it's how big the the surface is right
we're gonna come back to this
relationship a little while later but
for now I'm just gonna put it there why
did we say this one we're again what was
the use of stating it
yeah I'm after that derivative art I
okay so I'm gonna differentiate here
which gives me eight Pienaar very good
and this is what I can put into I don't
know why I read it over here this is
what I can put into here da on d R times
D are on DT okay
so let's see here da RDR is exactly
where I want it it's 8 PI R times and
dr/dt I've worked out over here right 35
on 2 PI R squared you do some canceling
for me and tell me what you get
sit a hundred and forty on looks like I
just on our on our all those pies will
cancel and we all shed a tear for the
pies okay so are you happy there does
that make sense now again we don't need
to write it out here but I think you can
see because this is even simpler right
what happens is the radius gets bigger
right well when you start off when you
start off with like a small value of r
like say one okay the rate of increase
of the surface area is 140 that's really
fast right it's like hoof it just
inflates right but as I gets bigger and
bigger alright for example by the time
you get to R equals 3 what is 140
divided by 3 it's like the 30 can take
40 something 44 ish okay so it's
dramatically decreased it's still
increasing but it gets slower and slower
and slower so in fact it's a hyperbola
isn't it see what's going on okay one
last thing all of this you can see we've
related volume and area and radius we've
also related to time but I haven't said
anything about any times here so I'm
going to ask you this question what if I
said can you tell me mmm let's get back
to radius for a second can you tell me
how the radius is changing after 10
seconds now you've got no formula here
which has T as in as a variable you
would insert here but I wonder if you
can work out how we would find out what
it is
what was the very first piece of
information I told you a very first one
give me on the tape right D V under t
equals 70 yeah now I want you to look
carefully at least for a second look
carefully because stuck tucked away
inside here is the relationship that
you're after
okay after one second what's the volume
one second to blowing the void is gonna
be 70 cubic millimeters right but after
two seconds it'll be that then we'll go
again right yeah you're Harvey you're
going back in time after two seconds
it'll be our hundred and forty after the
third second will be two hundred and ten
etc seventy one forty two ten to a how
would you describe that relationship
it's a constant well it's not constant
action it's not change it's changing
right so it's getting bigger the
gradient is constant though right so
here's what we can do remember we've
been using differentiation the thing you
haven't used yet is integration right so
if you look at this look at this guy
right get we grab another color for this
right have a look at this can you see
with this equation I can integrate both
sides what do you think would be
appropriate variable to choose what am I
trying to get to I'm trying to get to a
time right so I'm gonna integrate both
sides with respect to T that gives me
this like so then okay now I know that
left hand side looks a little bit weak
you're like what's going on with all
those duties that's okay
you can see it cancels you're just
integrating with respect to V now right
because the variable is actually changed
do you see that this is like just like
what we did when we were doing
integration by substitution the variable
has changed to you this is still 70 and
what are we gonna get V equals what
happens when you integrate a constant
with respect to T 70 T and don't forget
it's all indefinite so you'd say plus C
yeah now how do we work out that
constant by the way how do we find out
what would you usually do to fight
now what a constant is you need some
kind of value that you can substitute in
and then that cancels everything out
when you are about to stop blowing the
balloon what was its volume its volume
was zero at time zero when T equals zero
the volume will equal zero so in this
case as in many since V equals zero when
T equals zero it will all evaluate to C
will equal zero so that there is your
equation there now you've got a
relationship not just between volume and
radius vert volume and time okay do you
reckon you could work this out now I'm
gonna give you a couple minutes to have
a play and see if you can work out a
value for I will show all of you I think
some of you are sort of on the right
direction but I've sort of intentionally
throw you somewhat into the deep end
because I could just give you rules for
this but then you don't feel your way
through it which i think is actually a
really important part of learning this
let me help you out okay we know that V
equals 72 what does that mean as time
increases the volume increases at a rate
of 70 millimeters cubed per second okay
so after 10 seconds when T equals 10 for
10 seconds when t equals 10 the volume
equals 70 times 10 are you okay with
that so it's going to be 700 cubic
millimeters okay now I know how to work
out dr/dt if only have a look at my
equation for dr/dt over here here it is
my equation for dr/dt at the moment it
is in terms of its in terms of our do
you see that so if I know what R is if
only I can find out what R is I'll be
able to pop it into this equation how do
I find out R the radius if I know the
volume yeah okay there's the
relationship between volume and radius
right so I can say that's 700 that 700
is 4/3 PI R cubed that's what it's equal
to
okay so R cubed is just going to be
seven hundred divided by 4/3 pi whatever
that happens to be the
radius you actually want therefore is
just take the cube root and you'll have
some weird number but that's okay this
is just a workout for your calculator
really okay once you've got that radius
whatever it happens to be you can pop it
into here does anyone have a number for
it yet can someone tell me their number
once they get to it when R is that
terrible mess
what does dr/dt actually end up equaling
can someone give me a decimal couple of
decimal places of accuracy maybe what
are you offering off okay now let's just
do a quick sense check does this make
sense zero point one eight three six
that's quite low isn't it you expected
to come in sometime after this yeah
well that does make sense that the rate
of increase of the race drops off really
fast right and if you're going after two
ten seconds yeah it's it only went fast
at the beginning and then it slows down
quite quickly okay slows down quickly